let me share this one tip that in a
consulting firm like mckinsey everyone
up to the partner level applies all the
time next time that you communicate your
recommendation to a client or to a
colleague instead of saying well i
recommend this because of this reason
and then also because of this other
reason and then also because of this
other reason rather say it like this i
recommend this to you for three reasons
first this second this third this so
always start right away by saying you
will have three reasons then list them
one after the other but why three
reasons well if you have only one
argument that's usual enough it's always
possible to come up with a counter
argument to your argument if you have
two reasons well that's somewhat
convincing but not super strong yet if
you have four five six reasons ah you
know too many reasons i can't remember
it's so complicated three really is the
magic number here it's often also called
the rule of three so try this out and
let me know in the comments how this
works for you